[Música]
más de un millón de personas están sin
servicio de electricidad en Estados
Unidos debido a la tormenta invernal que
azota ese país 7000 vuelos han sido
cancelados y las temperaturas siguen
bajando drásticamente en diferentes
puntos de la Unión Americana
y Mientras tanto en Chile todo lo
contrario 7000 hectáreas arrasadas unas
200 viviendas destruidas y dos personas
fallecidas dejan hasta el momento los
incendios que afectan la ciudad de Piña
del mar en Chile debido a las altas
temperaturas del verano el gobierno
decretó el estado de catástrofe en la
zona
tres personas murieron y otras a tres
resultaron heridas en un tiroteo
ocurrido en frente de un centro cultural
kurdo ubicado en el centro de París la
capital francesa las autoridades avanzan
en la investigación para esclarecer las
causas de este hecho
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González vamos a comenzar en Estados
Unidos y lo hacemos haciendo una
actualización de la situación en ese
país debido a la tormenta invernal que
afecta buena parte del territorio de ese
país las autoridades indicaron que más
de un millón de personas se quedaron sin
servicio de Electricidad y más de 7.000
vuelos ya fueron cancelados los
meteorólogos advierten sobre el peligro
que representa este inusual fenómeno
climático el informe es de Rafael Pérez
una tormenta de nieve única en una
generación así calificó el National
Weather Service el fenómeno
meteorológico que potencialmente
afectará a más de 240 millones de la
población estadounidense las imágenes
satelitales muestran grandes masas de
aire sobre la Unión Americana alrededor
de 7.000 vuelos fueron cancelados
causando caos de Cara a la celebración
de Nochebuena
nos preocupa mucho que los vuelos se
retrasen o se cancelen afortuna ese no
es el caso hasta ahora pero he estado
ansiosa por traer a nuestra familia aquí
a tiempo tratando de ver a la familia
que no hemos visto en muchos años debido
al covid y las carreteras tampoco son
ajenas al problema los conductores se
enfrentan a una visibilidad casi nula en
la víspera al presidente Joe biden
advirtió de la magnitud de La tempestad
en una sesión informativa
por favor tómense esta tormenta muy en
serio Yo no sé si sus jefes los dejarán
pero si todos tienen planes de viaje
váyanse ahora no es broma
más de uno coma 25 millones de personas
se quedaron sin electricidad igual de
afectada se vio la paquetería por correo
en este sentido la empresa FedEx afirmó
que habría retrasos en las entregas a
nivel nacional para el sábado se espera
mejoras en las condiciones
meteorológicas a medida que la masa de
aire se desplace hacia el este
el congreso de Estados Unidos aprobó el
presupuesto para el año fiscal 2023 los
fondos para gastos alcanzan los 1,7
billones de dólares dentro de los cuales
están los 45.000 millones destinados
para la ayuda de Ucrania la cámara de
representantes dio su visto bueno a este
proyecto de ley por 225 votos a favor y
201 en contra esto tiene lugar solo un
día después de que el senado de mayoría
demócrata lo viera también validado por
68 votos positivos y 29 en contra
evitando así también un cierre del
Gobierno Federal Ahora solo resta la
firma del presidente Joe biden para que
el presupuesto entre en vigor
nos vamos ahora hasta el extremo sur del
continente hay tensión política en
Argentina luego de que la oposición
presentara una denuncia penal contra el
presidente Alberto Fernández La medida
tiene lugar después de que el mandatario
se negara a acatar un fallo de la Corte
Suprema que lo obligaba a restituir
fondos a la ciudad de Buenos Aires cuyo
gobierno local está dirigido
precisamente por la oposición Valentina
Torres Sánchez nos amplían su informe
A solo días de terminar los festejos
mundialistas la política devolvió la
atención y la polarización Argentina la
Corte Suprema de Justicia ordenó al
gobierno nacional que entregue unos 997
millones de dólares adicionales a la
ciudad de Buenos Aires que provienen de
los impuestos recaudados por el fisco se
trata de los llamados coparticipables
que se entregan entre las provincias y
la capital según una tabla de
porcentajes establecida por la ley en
2016 el entonces presidente Mauricio
macri aumento por decreto la suma que
recibía la ciudad de Buenos Aires del
uno coma cuarenta por ciento al
3,75%. esto justo cuando el gobierno
local quedaba en manos de Horacio
Rodríguez larreta su delfín político
posteriormente en 2020 el actual jefe de
estado Alberto Fernández recordó los
fondos a la capital del 3,75 al 2,32% y
ahora la corte dictaminó que pasen al
2,95% Fernández aseguró que no acatará
la resolución en un día aciago para el
federalismo para este fallo
tremendo que ha sacado la corte que
genera una enorme desigualdad
entre la ciudad más suculenta del país y
el resto del país la decisión de
Fernández generó un fuerte revuelo entre
la oposición la coalición cívica ya
presentó una demanda penal por
alzamiento desobediencia judicial abuso
de autoridad y violación de los deberes
de funcionario público el presidente
pidió presentó una recusación contra los
jueces de la corte para que no
participen en este proceso
Esto no es contra la ciudad esto es
contra la Constitución nacional
expertos aseguran que la decisión De no
respetar el fallo sí incumple la
Constitución y sectores de la oposición
ya consideran pedir un juicio político
contra Fernández
en la ciudad de viña del mar en Chile
las altas temperaturas del verano han
provocado incendios que han arrasado con
cerca de siete mil hectáreas han dañado
también 200 viviendas y han dejado hasta
el momento dos personas fallecidas las
conflagraciones se mantienen activas por
lo que el gobierno en la ciudad de
Santiago decretó el estado de catástrofe
en la zona Andrés triviño nos cuenta más
las altas temperaturas en Chile generan
estragos los residentes de viña del mar
en la costa central del país limpian los
daños de un gran incendio mientras las
llamas se mantienen vivas y afectan a
cientos de personas y hogares el
gobierno central decretó el estado de
catástrofe en la zona ordenaron subir a
todo andaba buscando una amiga
desaparecía pero no la puedo encontrar
es un caos es un caos esto una ola de
calor que ha azotado a Chile con
temperaturas récord en algunas zonas y
la falta de lluvias ha intensificado los
incendios forestales que ya han quemado
más de 7000 hectáreas en menos de una
semana las autoridades calculan que
entre 200 y 500 casas estarían afectadas
por las llamas en Viña del Mar Por lo
cual han desplegado helicópteros y
aviones cisterna además de brigadas
terrestres
Bueno tengo tenemos Pérdida total O sea
la familia yo la tengo tan de mi papá
que está más abajo Así que vine a ver
perdimos todo todo se puede decir
documento perdimos vehículo lo que más
siento son unas perrita que se me
quedaron adentro así que están por ahí
están Están muertas afectadas a las
casas de mi suegra la casa de mis amigos
bueno se perdió todo
los bomberos han informado que las
condiciones climáticas actuales podrían
contribuir a que el incendio sea
controlado prontamente
y en otros temas tres personas murieron
y otras tres resultaron heridas tras un
tiroteo que se produjo en el centro de
París la capital francesa enfrente de un
centro cultural kurdo etnia a la que
pertenecían las víctimas
la calle de John acordonada por la
policía ubicada en el distrito diez de
París alberga un centro comunitario
kurdo fue allí en pleno día donde un
individuo abrió fuego el restaurante y
la peluquería vecinos también kurdos
fueron atacados
vimos gente corriendo y luego entramos
en la peluquería y vimos que había tres
heridos en la peluquería entonces me
pidieron que llamara a los bomberos
el presunto autor de 69 años ya era
conocido por la policía en particular
por un ataque contra inmigrantes así lo
ha confirmado la fiscal de París en el
lugar de los hechos
se trata de personas que estaban
instaladas en tiendas de campaña y la
persona en cuestión atacó estas tiendas
se abrió una investigación a finales de
2021 y la persona en cuestión ha sido
puesta en libertad recientemente
herido sobre todo en la cara el
sospechoso fue trasladado al hospital en
estado de relativa urgencia acto seguido
fue detenido la brigada criminal se hizo
cargo de la investigación fue un acto
racista Las investigaciones tendrán que
decirlo una cosa es cierta Esta es una
de las líneas de la investigación
y la cunda por el ataque la comunidad
kurda de París reaccionó
una de las víctimas asesinadas Hoy era
una de las responsables del movimiento
de mujeres kurdas en Francia Por eso hay
un carácter político Por eso hay un
carácter terrorista que nadie intente
hacernos creer que se trata de un simple
atentado orquestado por la extrema
derecha
el presidente Manuel macron reaccionó
ante el hecho calificando los teatros
así también lo hizo la primera ministra
Elizabeth born quien manifestó pleno
apoyo a las víctimas
es todo por el momento en las noticias
de France 24 siga con nosotros
[Música]